valérie benaïm et pretty valérie benaïm
est prête valérie ça y est benhaim est
ce que vous entendez ouais ouais ouais à
les révéler mais ce que vous m'entendez
oui commença alors valérie bénaïm ses
très sincères qui bat la cité j'avais le
coeur qui bat je le sais alors on a une
famille et il a envoyé une vidéo valérie
à la voir tout de suite c'est parti
regardez la vidéo
la femme la vidéo j'espère alors je vous
jure
apparemment n'a plus rien donc voilà on
est faute au sérieux cette famille sont
ils ont ils ont eu des quadruplés les
chéris il s'appelle refrain et nasser il
m'avait interpellé à la fin de
l'émission je crois qu'ils sont dans le
public on fera les la série sont enfin
la serre ils sont là bas ils sont
magnifiques ils sont venus ils sont
venus me voir un jour et i mode et on a
eu des quadruplés et cyril c'est très
très dur pour nous donc j'aimerais les
aider parce qu'ils veulent absolument
acheter une voiture cette place avoir
une voiture c'est parce que voilà quand
on a des quadruplés du jour au lendemain
c'est compliqué donc je me suis je vais
les aider ont peut-être en leur offrant
un an de courses comme ça au moins les
courses c'est réglé comme ça ils peuvent
débloquer un petit peu d'argent pour
acheter la boîte
alors valérie bénaïm valérie bénaïm vous
allez tout de suite de voir l'europe
gros le vert défi ouais vous allez
rentrer dans une pièce non non non non
non non non non non non non c'est tout
noir n'ont été rappelé à la black box un
enfant c'est une pierre tout nous c'est
une pièce toute noire où il ya des
blagues riez pas il ya des blagues c'est
pas des blagues
bah vous allez voir vous allez avoir de
mieux pour entrer dans la pièce et
trouver le cadeau il est facile à
trouver puisqu'il est dans un paquet
cadeau 28 ans rassurez vous je vais vous
guider avec le son de ma douce voix je
veux pas de ça j'étais juré vos yeux et
vous serez mes mains non mais est quand
même aimé mes mains moi elles vont venir
dans ta gueule à toi y'a pas juste ce
qu'on ya pas d certes on est d'accord ne
vous inquiétez pas on and on me dit pas
le serpent le seul serpent et dans mon
slip
non pardon excusez moi merci
allez valérie bénaïm vont entrer dans la
black box et par les centrales et
valérie benaïm et on vous enlèvera votre
bandeau vous à qui dénote un certain
j'ai peur a laissé filer plein on évoque
benhaim aller n'ayez pas peur ya papa
tosh et je vais où l'a arrêté j'ai peur
à les otages si les retards de trains à
temps les rentrées mais pas très
complètement nathan est entré
complètement benhaim benhaim on entend
des m'avoir ya que ma voix à benali je
me sens bien mais c'est pas bien mais
arrêtez les algériens vous inquiétez pas
je te jure j'aime pas vite il vous reste
une minute quarante bien tu sais pas
quoi faire j'adore comme il le pousse
john f
j'en ai ma bande en bas âge elle va nous
enlever le bandeau mon dieu j'ai peur
allez-y mailei qu'est ce que je fais il
avait une minute trente de trouver le
cadeau tu as tu sais pas si recherche
chargé recherche ben ali michèle cotta
avancé je ne peux pas mais là il va
avancer il faut qu'on nous autorise à
l'ewi alesi a laissé très peur allez-y
vous avez une trappe à garder à l'oeil à
un petit pot à votre droite année j'y
mettais les maintenant mais mon dieu si
c'est rien à les y mettez leur ado sait
rien allez-y arrête ya que des blagues
arrête de parler je t'en supplie lui
parler jimena hibarette mais naïveté toi
je te jure
ferme ta [ __ ] de viol ben ali est à
toi arrête je te supplie je t'en supplie
je ne peux pas le faire l'offrir mois le
cadeau non attends c'est un autre bon
maître à tous c'est quoi
mais la lime salon c'est rien tu vois ça
allez vas-y abass abass île en forme de
coeur il n'ya pas il ya un truc à tirer
un moment il est ou a tiré au dessus de
toi lève la tête regard ya une crainte
bah ouais voilà non avant son corps
avant son corps que je vois nazis avance
avance avance avance avance avant de
l'inviter jusqu'à sion vient ta gueule
l'êta lance alors je peine à ibos l'est
vraiment l'aimant l'air a choisi tout
janiec trop facile foule
oui
ah ah
[Musique]
benaïssa peu avant sa poche je te jure
qu'on jette des fonds j'te mme arafat
est témoin jean claude van damme [ __ ]
la main
des années s'est barré c'est assez
délicat mais que des blagues mais je te
merde mais la déteste valérie bénard a
trouvé comment voyez reinacker à écouter
en tout cas les avez quoi comme à la
tire et la trappe
geoff rowley un gars
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà temps d'attenté attendre à ce que
c'est fini c'est fini mais à messieurs
très vite s'il vous plaît merci et juste
attendez attendez les cherry est ce
qu'on peut savoir est ce que vous êtes
content un an de courses à vous faire du
bien les chérir alors un an de course
heureusement je suis hyper content pour
vous les shérifs je sais vous avez eu
des quadruplés aujourd'hui on fête les
cliques voilà il me rasant nouveau
projet vraiment de quoi offrir neuf en
cours
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
course bouge pas
grâce à 12
c'est un bébé voilà bravo bravo
[Applaudissements]
la bourse
bouteflika ni leur contrat rafale est ce
que tu as un truc à dire ma chérie à
redon est ce que tu as des trucs à dire
machine franchement je remercie notre
famille qui sont là pour nous tous les
jours je fais un gros bisou à mes
enfants c'est des guerriers sont nés
prématurés ils ont fait leurs preuves et
vraiment souhaité nous que du bonheur et
que notre belle continue comme ça rincez
abondamment merci filligent bercy
valérie franchement merci à toute
l'équipe est au top
elle était formidable merci merci
messieurs les nouveaux fonds